it's the most incredible evening I ever
thought possible
and had a lot of written words and a lot
of thoughts but I had no idea this was
going to be anything like this I when
when it was a prepared I mean F
presented to me by mr. Hebert camp a
paper camp of the Academy I and my wife
had said yes he'll do it this is before
she spoke to me and I really I'm I'm I'm
bummed I can't believe it I'm so
embarrassed till here the people talking
about me because I assume when I'm not
around
it's a totally different conversation
but um it's my body I mean you have no
idea whoever out there they've been
honored or got an award or it's you sit
here and you look out you listen to all
those people talk about him you say that
that me is it really it's hard to
understand I I just I got very fortunate
and then I was able to make movies I
would have been an out-of-work actor now
if it hadn't been for a great director
named Marty RIT who you all knew
I had a apart on his live shows in those
days it was a two lines or less and I
was two lines or less actually had one
line and I got into a silly discussion
with him
and that night of rehearsal the day of
the rehearsal for that night and he
turned to me said your problem is you
can't take direction and I know God
thank you very much each of you do you
ought to be a director I said thank you
easier said than done and because I'd
been hanging with him a little bit he
said you're my assistant on the next
show and it turned my life around I
never went back to acting so is this
whole thing is a list of things I was
supposed to say and but I'm serious if
she's sitting there tonight listening to
all my friends and I they are my friends
I did this whole thing doesn't make any
sense because from the heart I love
every one of those and these people that
were up there tonight a changed my life
I didn't change theirs they brought
something to my life I never knew
possible and that was you know in
directing it when I was started and
directing with them and started in
commercials but documentaries but when I
got into television for some crazy
reason I I was fortunate enough to get
hired for shows like everything from
route 66 with the great actress Nina
foix to Gilligan's Island and I loved it
and they never put me in a corner
they it went on like that for many a
year and hundreds of TV shows and it was
also
it's also untethered I was able to
switch from one of the other and so when
I got into the opportunity of doing
films same thing happens it's just been
amazing I mean from doing Radio Flyer
more maxes bar what the hell is it um
what insight moves I'm losing in I
thought I grabbed sliding to smoke a
little weed before I came on stage but
it it just didn't happen and I'm caught
an alert here Jerry moss I know you're
holding going up here
but anyway it's it's um it's it's an
extraordinary experience i sat here and
listened and watched and I really said
did that me I had somebody said it
earlier that's all confusing now but I
never did pay dues people would say well
you paid your dues I never did I've been
the luckiest person in the world this
business has been incredible I've had
nothing but friends and Nora Ephron told
Lauren Lauren produced a wonderful
picture with Nora and Nora told Lauren
she said you know in every movie you
make the one good thing about it is you
come out with a new friend and it's so
true but I came out with so many of them
it's extraordinary I just this industry
is my friend and it's been just the
greatest gift in the world to me and I
don't know what to say I I I'd there
were a couple of bad moments couple bad
dudes
that stepped in our way and and turned a
dream into a nightmare but even those I
kind of excused in it in a way now
because they're driving they were driven
to be part of this industry and they
would maybe go about the wrong way to
get there but we've all seen the gone
about it go about the right way and I
love it I don't know whether I got to
look at these notes now and I say what
did I miss I missed oh wow
I was going to say I never thought I
would say this but I want to thank the
Academy
[Applause]